you see me basic gym gay sisters I'm
gone
[Music]
by any animal feed the power
[Music]
Salam alaikum warahmatullah better care
to brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to this video before I start
what I want to do is I want to go
straight into the clip where a specific
incident incident that happened at the
park about last week or two weeks ago
where the the far-right Tommy's fans
came to the park and some of them wanted
to speak to me but because it was
getting dark and some of them were drunk
and was going to be a hostile my
teachers told me and brothers told me
that I should leave the park so I was
posed to speak to some of them so let's
just watch the footage as exactly what
happened
[Music]
Ali are to the debate love you long time
so guys as you saw that footage this
lady came to me and she wanted to speak
to me obviously but I had to go because
like I said of the events that were
taking place and if you can see very
comfortably she put her arm around me
very comfortably and it was a hug you
know she poor arm around me now some of
you might just disregard in fear what's
wrong with this you know it's not a big
deal but when you guys imagine if a
Muslim man imagine me going to the park
and this lady this woman is there and I
put my arm around her and I tried to
speak to her what would happen what do
you think what do you think Tommy would
say what do you think the far out would
say you know they would say look at him
he has no respect he's putting his arm
around her this is what they're known
for
grooming and all this kind of nonsense
yeah this what they would say now I
wanted to highlight this issue because
it's very very important you know that
if it's done by a man to a female or a
female down to a man nobody has the
right to touch another person physically
it's not that it's not it shouldn't be
allowed now I'm not saying this person
did it with sexual intent or any kind of
intent no but it just I just wanted to
bring highlight it to you guys that
imagine if it was a Muslim man imagine
Muslim man doing that to a Muslim woman
you know so let's not have double
standards and I'm happy to speak to them
in the future time mushara but what I
want to talk to you guys about is
another thing which is that as we guys
not as Christmas and Christians are
celebrating their Christmas they have
this big misconception that we as
Muslims find it so offensive so this
Christmas tree behind me so so offensive
to me when I see I start crying and I'm
like oh no